all right we're back at e3 2014 with
Maxell Magee who just saw Mortal Kombat
X yeah this is one of the games I'm
definitely most excited about to check
out here at the show and there are a lot
of changes coming in more Kombat X
compared to the previous MK 9 so you're
gonna have to explain some of this week
because this is a series that I used to
love quite a bit sure the latest
iterations of the game I found a bit
unbalanced a bit unwieldy but the
trailer that they showed at least with
the gameplay bin looked really smooth
and I guess maybe can you elaborate on
how these games are different from like
injustice or combat 9 yeah on the note
of the smoothness of the game that was
something I asked about right away -
developer in that in that trailer they
showed it did look very fluid very
smooth and that's something they have
been actively working on they realized
that their games do kind of look like
two robots fighting with each other so
they've been going to greater pains to
just sort of one speed up the action and
to create more animations to just link
different moves together so you're not
like popping from one attack to another
one quite so much you're like naturally
transitioning between them as so far as
this game is different from injustice
one of the big changes I was excited to
see is what they're doing with the
interactive is the stage interactable x'
and the things you can do in the
environment and injustice it got a
little crazy where like some characters
use interactable x' to jump around the
screen some characters would like smash
you over the head with a car or whatever
and MK toon all characters use the
background interactable x' in the same
way and most of those interactable our
mobility based so the balance is a
little bit more yeah reasonable it's a
little more even across yes and another
thing that i really liked was like in
the bat-cave and injustice you could run
up to the Batmobile and just like spam
the missiles out of the Batmobile over
and over you can't do that so much in MK
10:1 because most of the interactable is
again our mobility based in true because
using an interactive mode now requires a
little bit of stamina meter because it's
a new fighting game so naturally we have
to have more meters in it like you do
like you do so you can't just go around
spamming interactable is over and over
now
just gonna train your standard yeah can
you tell me a bit about I guess the
variants they talked about characters
will have multiple versions this isn't
just costumes right yeah well it
actually does affect costumes as well
but basically each character has three
different variants that affects his his
or her play style I asked the developer
like do you guys even think of a
character as being like a Zoning
character or a grappler or like a
Russian on care team or and that's not
really the case because the variants are
gonna let you play in all sorts of
different styles of the same character
so I played a lot as Devorah who's like
the bug woman with like the we got
insect arms coming up inside and so she
had a variant that like let her throw a
bug bomb that's dumb people and another
one that shot like poison atom and
another one that was a little more melee
focused so she can be played up close
she can play far away um and then yeah
like I mentioned it also affects their
outfits - this is a fun cosmetic thing
so like in one style she's got her hood
up and another one her hoods down and
another one she has like poison dripping
from her hands and feet and stuff so
there's a lot of there's a lot of
neatness to be explored there this game
sounds a lot more interesting to me
compared to the last few games from
Boonen team so I know I'm excited are
you looking forward to it I'm definitely
looking forward to this game I think
it's gonna be a it'll definitely be a
competitive contender and as long as
they stay true they're not ready to talk
about the single-player suite at this
point but I know nk9 had like that crazy
story mode that people loved it at the
challenge tower all the developer would
say it was like they realized and
recognized that stuff that people loved
so I think we'll probably be able to
expect similar things cool well that's
Mortal Kombat X from Axl McGee thanks
for joining me stay tuned a game spot
for more info from the e3 2014 show
floor
you